my laser focus is on growing the
nation's economy
and creating jobs if i had had to write
down my best guess it would have been
higher but
actually what happened is stronger i
think than the headline number
looks just before the weekend we got
this april jobs report and it was just
egregiously bad now when i say
egregiously bad i mean compared to
expectations we had about 266 thousand
jobs added to the american economy and
there's a downgrade of the number of
jobs that had been expected to grow
the prior month as well it was supposed
to be in march it was supposed to be
like 900
and 16 000 jobs and end up being about
770 000 jobs
in april it ended up being 266 000 jobs
now most economists expected a million
job increase a million job increase
obviously
expectations wildly missed according to
the washington post the u.s economy
added just 266 000 jobs in april a
disappointing month of growth that fell
well below
economist estimates despite declining
virus caseloads and increased vaccine
distribution
around the country the april
unemployment rate remained relatively
unchanged at 6.1 percent
although economists caution the number
is misleadingly low given how many
people have dropped out of the labor
force in the past year
the news increased political pressure in
washington amid concerns about whether a
labor shortage reported in some pockets
of the economy is slowing down
the recovery the white house rejected
that notion on friday instead
they said no no everything is fine right
here for example was president biden
saying
these job numbers they show that we're
on the right track well except for the
fact that
um this was a completely unexpected
slowing we had
as of just before the pandemic some
152.5 million people who were employed
we have right now about 144.3 million
people who are employed so we are still
eight million jobs short of where we
work here's the thing we have 7.4
million job openings right now but
nobody's filling those job openings why
because when you pay people to stay home
you know what they do they stay home
here's joe biden pretending that his
idiotic economic recovery packages
haven't somehow softened the economy
this month's job numbers show we're on
the right track
we still have a long way to go as i said
my laser focus
is on growing the nation's economy and
creating jobs
i mean his real laser focus is on
ensuring that he makes sure that he
tivo's matlock but
aside from that his laser focus
apparently is on pursuing policies that
greatly
soften the economy greatly soften the
economy because here's the thing what we
are currently experiencing
is exactly what you would expect if you
know anything about economic history
when you blow a bunch of money
into an economy that was already in a
state of recovery and when you talk
about how you are going to tax everybody
who creates jobs
out the wazoo what you end up with is
slow economic growth
and massive inflation and indeed even
cnn is picking up
on this according to cnn over the
weekend everywhere you look there are
headlines about higher prices
some are tied to commodities which are
getting snapped up as the global economy
emerges from its long slumber
lumber prices are at an all-time high
thanks to an epic home building boom
copper and steel prices have also
reached records
agricultural products aren't exempt the
price of corn is at its highest level
since 2012 same for soybeans
even sales of block cheese futures have
been soaring in anticipation of grilling
season
then there are consumer products diaper
prices have gone up two major producers
kimberly clark
and proctor gamble have warned customers
that fresh hikes are coming as well
shortages of computer chips are helping
to push up car prices soon could do the
same for electronics and household
appliances
says cnn this doesn't just matter for
americans guarding their pocketbooks
price increases are also being closely
scrutinized by investors
and economists are desperate to know is
this a passing phenomenon as the country
emerges from a once in a lifetime
economic shock
or a more sustained trend that evokes
the 1970s now normally
it is true that you would end up with
higher prices in a time with greater
demand and lower supply but the point is
that then
demand would be caught up to by supply
right as the demand is high and supply
is low
you'd be able to ramp up the supply to
meet demand that's usually how supply
and demand curves work but
when you're artificially preventing
people from employing anybody well then
it turns out what you get is
hyperinflation
right this is when you end up with the
with the money that you have in the bank
being worth less than it was yesterday
because the products are just more
expensive and this is happening across
labor markets
and i was talking yesterday to a small
business owner we went out for mother's
day
for brunch for my wife and for my my
wife's mom
and we went to this restaurant and there
was like one waiter
and the restaurant was packed there's
one waiter and the owner came out and we
were talking to the owner and the owner
said yeah i had seven people who were
supposed to show up for work this week
and instead they said no no no i'm not
gonna show up for work because i'm
getting paid too much to stay home
i mean that is a common story that
you're hearing from small businesses
across the country and you're hearing it
over and over small business owners are
saying
openly that the reason that they cannot
ramp up supply is because they cannot
get people to come into work
there are people who are paying bonuses
just to keep people to just to get
people to interview for jobs
i was hearing rumors that there are
chain restaurants that are now paying
people like 50 bucks just to show up for
an interview
because people are not showing up when
you pay unemployment benefits have now
been extended all the way through
september
even though the pandemic is effectively
over in many states in the union right
now
so far as the economy is concerned
there's a reason that governor
ron desantis in florida is saying listen
you need to show actual effort that
you're going to try and get a job if
you're going to continue to get
unemployment benefits
the white house has has not been nearly
so forthcoming
and they're trying to deny all of this
they're trying to pretend that none of
this is happening
so janet yellen over at the federal
reserve who last week admitted that
inflation is going to kick in
and then said well you know we can
handle it if it does presumably
by by getting rid of some of their bond
holdings instead of buying bonds in the
open market and
and trying to ramp up the the open
markets rate the overnight rate for the
feds
well i mean maybe you can do that or
maybe this is going to run out of
control because you've created too much
of a barrier in the economy to people
getting back to work
here is jannie ellen the treasury
secretary saying no no everything's fine
if i had had to write down a number as
my best guess it would have been higher
but
i've watched data for a long time and
i know that it is extremely volatile
there are often surprises and temporary
factors
and one should never take one month's
data is an underlying
trend besides remember i said then the
the
actually what happened is stronger i
think than the headline number looks
okay the in other words don't believe
the numbers believe me
that it'll be fine or maybe it won't
because
this job reports this jobs report missed
by three quarters of a million jobs okay
that is a
lot of jobs a lot of jobs in a second
we're going to talk about
all the various ways the white house is
trying to spin this but again the
reality is that when you spend a bunch
of money that nobody needed and by the
way when americans were paid to stay
home last year so
actually the amount of money that
americans have in the bank right now is
actually higher than it was before the
pandemic
by statistics so people are ready to
spend but they're not ready to work
and that is a massive gap that is going
to have significant downstream effect
on the economy and that is what you are
seeing did you know that every single
like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science
[Music]
ugh